les travaux estivaux ont déjà commencé à
ou dans le département aide à la
construction d'une bretelle de sortie de
la rn 12 et la rd 912 via un giratoire
l'été une période propice pour réaliser
ce type d'opération d'envergure
on va estimer qu' on est sur une période
longue
on peut ouvrir un chantier sur plusieurs
semaines
on peut estimer aussi que la météo sera
au rendez vous c'est à dire pas trop de
pluie et des conditions agréables pour
pouvoir travailler dans tous les cas les
matériaux dont on a besoin
je pense aux couches de roulement je
n'ai pas gêné parce qu'il fait par froid
sera pas gelée
on peut le faire dernier sujet la
circulation est moindre elles le volume
diminue
au total 60 travaux vont être engagés
cet été sur le département parmi les
plus importants la rénovation de la
chaussée de la rd 988 à rochefort en
yvelines
l'entretien du pont de franchissement de
loi situé entre andrésy et conflans
sainte honorine
les travaux d'aménagement giratoire du
carrefour de la rd 154 entre orgeval et
vilaine sur scène
le reste du réseau routier sera
également entretenus sur des secteurs
identifiés
on va encore en fonction des aléas
climatiques
mais surtout de la densité de
circulation vous avez beaucoup de
camions qui passent sur une chaussée
elle est évidemment plus détériorés que
si vous avez un route départementale
avec un ou deux milliers de voitures
jour alors que quand je parle de deux ou
trois mille voitures heures c'est pas la
même chose
au total le département des yvelines va
engager 30 millions d'euros de travaux
sur la période estivale sur six mille
six cents kilomètres de routes